MASUD HASAN: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to our session DA307.
My name is Masud, cloud
solution architect at Google,
and I have joined
here with Abdul,
lead architect, Cybersecurity
Analytics at TELUS.
We'd like to talk to you about
how we have built a network
anomaly detection solution to
find outliers in NetFlow log.
We'll focus on four key areas.
First, how we have simulated
production-like volume
in a Pub/Sub
[? topic. ?] Secondly,
a Dataflow anomaly detection
pipeline to aggregate data
and extract features
in a fixed window.
Thirdly, create a
[INAUDIBLE] clustering model
using BigQuery ML for
trained and normalized data.
But before we get
into details, I
would like to hand
it over to Abdul,
who is going to give us
a little bit of context
about the problem we
are trying to solve
and details about TELUS.
Over to you, Abdul.
ABDUL RAHMAN SATTAR:
Thank you, Masud.
Hi, everyone.
My name Abdul Rahman
Sattar, and I'm
the lead architect for
cybersecurity analytics
at TELUS.
I would also like
to acknowledge over
here the support of
Janahan Skandaraniyam, who
is responsible for
cybersecurity analytics at TELUS
and is the creator and driver
of the initiatives at TELUS
associated with
this presentation,
and Ragulan Sinnarajah,
who is responsible for
cybersecurity DevOps at TELUS.
So a little about TELUS.
We are Canada's fastest-growing
national telecommunications
company, with over 13.4
million customer connections
across our networks.
We are a leader in technology,
culture, and sustainability.
And we are committed to
giving where we live,
and we are the first
Canadian company
recognized as the world's
outstanding philanthropic
company.
Cybersecurity at TELUS is led
by a talented 400-strong team,
protecting both TELUS and
our security customers.
Innovation is a key
value in our team,
and we strive to push the
boundaries at the cutting
edge of technology.
Of late, the idea of
using big data data
analytics for
cybersecurity use cases
has become prevalent across
numerous industries--
areas such as smart
grids and SCADA systems,
autonomous/connected vehicles,
security operation centers,
health care systems can
benefit from this intersection
of big data analytics
and cybersecurity.
The pinnacle of
collaboration would
be prevention of damage caused
by malicious cybersecurity
activity due to an exceptionally
accurate prediction
of such activity
before it even occurs.
The gold or oil that runs the
engine of big data analytics
anywhere in any
industry is data.
No matter how good your
advanced analytics algorithms
are, unless they've
been enriched
with vast amounts of data,
the results they provide
will not be up to par.
And this is where TELUS,
like other organizations who
have access to unique
data, has a key advantage.
We carry the bulk of the
nation's communication data
across our pipelines.
We have a continuous stream of
both labeled and unlabeled data
from very diverse data sources,
enabling the application
of state-of-the-art advanced
analytics techniques to detect
malicious communications.
Anomalous
communication detection
can be used as a first step
for malicious communication
detection, and this presentation
goes to that first step
and shows how we can use
Google's tech stack to power
anomaly detection.
So now, I'd start zooming
in on the architecture
of the anomaly detection engine
that we've deployed on-premise
on TELUS.
So anomaly detection is one
of the several analytics use
cases running on a shared
multi-tenant Hadoop 2 data
lake at TELUS.
The end goal of anomaly
detection is twofold--
one, to build baseline models
for subscriber communications,
and second, to use those
baseline models to identify
anomalous subscriber
communication
and publish them downstream
during the [? inferencing ?]
stage.
And then, downstream, we have
multiple analytics components
running that pick up these
anomalous points identified
by the anomaly detection
engine and correlate them
with other alerts that we
got about the subscriber who
identified malicious
user behavior.
On the left of
the slide, you see
the tech stack that we've
deployed the anomaly detection
engine on.
So we've divided the tech
stack into three swim lanes.
So at the bottom, you see that
we have Yarn and HDFS deployed
on physical nodes.
So we use Yarn for resource
orchestration and resource
management.
We also use Yarn resource
queues for our resource quota
amongst various cluster tenants.
We use HDFS for reliable
and distributed storage.
And then in the
middle swim lane,
you see that we've deployed
Spark and multiple libraries
of Spark--
Spark Core, Spark
ML, Spark Streaming.
And we use Spark for distributed
compute for its ability
to do compute in a
distributed fashion,
and for stream processing and
batch processing workloads
at scale.
We also leverage Spark
ML quite a bit to machine
learning at scale, both
for training models and for
[? inferencing. ?]
And then on top, you see
in the top swim lane,
you see that we have various
Spark applications running
for anomaly detection
engine on our cluster.
We also use Splunk for
visualization and dashboards.
And with Splunk Query Language,
we give external teams
ability to do ad hoc queries
on the data, both raw data
and [? detections ?] that
reside on our data lake.
So in this slide, you see
an end-to-end architecture,
pipeline architecture, for
the anomaly detection engine
that we have at TELUS.
So the architectural diagram is
divided into three swim lanes.
We have ingest at the left.
Then we have
processing swim lane,
in which we have multiple
Spark applications running.
And then we have storage,
where we use HDFS.
So what's happening over here
is that the subscriber flow
logs is wrapped up
in syslog stream,
and it's being streamed
to the Hadoop cluster.
From there on in
the Hadoop cluster,
we have featured
extraction engine
which uses Spark streaming
to pick up this data stream.
It uses a fixed-size
window of five minutes
to create mini
batches, and then it
does additional processing
of those mini batches.
It does feature extraction,
it does feature enrichment,
and then it does aggregation.
And that process batch is then
written to HDFS for storage.
And you can see in number
two, in label number two.
And then what's
happening downstream
is that the modeling
engine essentially
picks up that processed batch--
and you can see that
in number three--
and it applies k-means
clustering on it.
It does distributed
k-means clustering
and build clusters
for user behavior,
for user communication behavior.
And it extracts other material
about those clusters as well.
It uses cluster mean, cluster
variance, cluster density,
and all of that metadata,
the clusters that we
have identified in this stage,
are written to HDFS or storage.
Then downstream, what
happens is that you
see in the anomaly
detection engine,
we fetch those clusters that
were identified that were built
by the modeling engine, and also
the batches that were processed
by the feature extraction engine
where features were extracted.
Those batches and the
models are fetched
by the anomaly detection engine,
and the anomaly detection
engine applies models
to those process batches
to identify anomalous
communication behavior.
And the way it identifies
anomalous communication
behavior is by
taking into account
all the metadata that we
extracted about the cluster.
We use cluster centroid.
We use cluster mean, cluster
variance, cluster density.
And the anomalies
are a function--
is a function of all
these parameters.
And once the anomalies
are identified,
they are stored to
HDFS and are also
published downstream,
where, as I said before,
the downstream analytics
components used
those anomalies
identified and correlate
them with other alerts
for the subscriber
to identify malicious
user behavior.
So why did we--
what prepared us to use GCP?
So we are a small
team, and what we
find is that our
time not only goes
into analytics and to developing
cybersecurity analytics,
but quite a bit of
time is also spent
on infrastructure
troubleshooting, infrastructure
management.
And that's where we
want to leverage GCP's
serverless architecture
capabilities,
so that we can be hands-free
from the infrastructure
management and infrastructure
troubleshooting issues.
With state-of-the-art
services that GCP provides,
like Dataflow and
Google BigQuery,
both of them are
serverless services.
We want to focus on our
core value prop, which
is cybersecurity analytics.
Additionally, Google BigQuery
is a state-of-the-art query
engine.
It's blazingly fast on
large amounts of data,
and it brings a lot of machine
learning capabilities out
of the box.
So we want to tap into BigQuery
to create models for us
to do faster iteration
on model-building.
And that allows us to
move at a fast speed.
Additionally, Google
BigQuery actually
has a dead simple SQL interface
which a lot of data scientists
are familiar with, and that
simplifies our code quite a bit
and, again, allows us
to do model-building
at a very fast pace.
And the code that we have,
because it's SQL code,
is easier to maintain as well.
And it removes
all the complexity
that we have as a
result of Spark ML.
And then, by having our
data in Google BigQuery,
it enables AutoML.
So AutoML essentially
allows you to build
baseline models very quick.
And that feature allows
us to test our own machine
learning models and
benchmark the performance
of our own machine
learning models.
And the elastic architecture
capabilities in Google and GCP
allows us to have
streamlined resource usage
and have a better cost
model for our pipeline.
So essentially, this
is the architecture
that we landed in our GCP pilot.
Essentially, when
you look at it,
it's very similar
to the architecture
that we had on-prem for our
anomaly detection engine
pipeline.
There are still
three swim lanes.
It's ingest, its process,
and the ingest swim lane,
the process swim lane,
and the store swim lane.
But what we have
done over here is
that instead of using
Hadoop tools and frameworks,
like Spark, and
Spark ML, and HDFS,
we've gone entirely
Google-native.
We're using Dataflow and Beam.
So Beam is a
vendor-agnostic framework.
We're using Dataflow,
which is serverless.
We're using Pub/Sub.
We're using Cloud Storage.
We're using BigQuery.
BigQuery essentially is acting
as a data warehouse for us
and allows us to
search [INAUDIBLE]
at really fast speed.
Also, BigQuery provides us with
machine learning capability
as I mentioned, and it allows
us for faster model-building
and simplifies our
machine learning code.
So with that, I would
actually pass on to Masud,
we can discuss the intricacies
of this architecture.
MASUD HASAN: All
right, thanks, Abdul.
So if you look at this
internal architecture,
let's dig a little bit more.
So first thing is your
ingestion trigger.
So if you look at
the [INAUDIBLE]
ingest architectures, we have
two different sources of data
that we are dealing with.
One is Cloud Storage, and
the other one is Pub/Sub.
Now, for production
settings, you somehow
need to pass those data to the
storage and the Pub/Sub topic,
either through
[INAUDIBLE] plugging,
or through [INAUDIBLE] connect.
Now, what we did for our POC,
because we could not get access
to all the production
data because
of the sensitive information,
we created a tool
using open source
Java Beam, which
we could simulate to create
250,000 messages per second
in a Pub/Sub topic.
And I'm going to get
into a little bit more
on details on that.
But now that we have all
the data in a Pub/Sub topic,
the second step
would be to process.
And we have built
a Dataflow pipeline
that aggregates those
data in a fixed window
and then do a batch insert for
a partition table in BigQuery.
If there is any outliers found,
we also stream those data
to a different table on BigQuery
so that further analysis
can be done.
Now, a lot of those logics
and you know everything that's
happening within that
process, we pretty much
rebuild it from scratch.
If you remember when Abdul
mentioned about the Spark,
this is actually built
on Apache Beam Java
SDK with a serverless
architecture
on top of XULRunner.
Now, the third thing
was, so now the data,
we have it on BigQuery.
What we wanted to do
is to be able to see
how easily we could train them.
And using a BigQuery ML
[INAUDIBLE] training model,
we could easily train them,
and also to normalize.
In terms of how to make sure
that it's used in a production
environment, what
we did is we put all
the [INAUDIBLE] statement for
the QML in a stored procedure.
And when you have usage
within [? scheduled ?] query
within BigQuery, now
you could literally
retrain the data
in either ad hoc,
or also whenever you
wanted to use it--
let's say in a scheduled manner.
Now, in addition to this,
you also see the Cloud DLP.
As I say there, may be
some sensitive information
on the log, so we
also tried to use
Cloud DLP for the detection,
for any sensitive information
like IMSI number
or subscriber ID.
We automated the
whole process using
CloudScale for CICD purposes.
Now, for the next few slides,
what we wanted to go through
is some of the challenges we had
to building this architecture.
So let's take
[? it in. ?] So as I said,
we needed to find a
tool that we could
use to leverage for simulation
of production data load.
Now if you look at what's
inside this Dataflow pipeline,
it actually uses a open
source JSON library.
On the right-hand side,
you could see a JSON schema
that I have.
And if you look at the
schema that we have,
it's very similar to
the NetFlow log schema.
So for example, you have
fields like subscriber ID,
source IP, destination IP.
And for each one of
those attributes,
it's associated with a function.
So for example,
source IP has IPv4.
What that would do is it would
generate a random IPv4 address
for source IP.
Now if you look at a
lot of those fields,
like a long and
integers, you could also
set up the range
for those [? both ?]
and the different
attributes that we have.
Now, the challenge
was, when you use
that, when you use that library
within the Dataflow pipeline,
we just need to make sure that
we have put enough workers so
that we could reach to our
target message per second goal.
So for our case,
what we noticed was
it was around 3,000 messages
per second [INAUDIBLE]..
So we added around 30
N1 standard for workers,
and it could easily reach out
to that production volume.
There's another challenge that I
just quickly wanted to mention.
If you look at the
schema, it's very random.
But we cannot be
completely random.
So for example, [? fit ?]
like destination IP,
we needed to make
sure that because we
are going to do a group by
on destination IP, somehow,
we limit the number of IPs
that we're going to test it on.
So this tool allows
us to be very flexible
and create function like Submit.
Or also, if you
think about, end time
has to be after start time.
So those kind of
features we could easily
build in so that our data
is very production-like.
So now that we have all the
information or all the data
published on the
Pub/Sub topic, this
is where all the fun starts.
We have built a, I would
say, pretty complex Dataflow
pipeline, pretty much
simulated whatever the logic
that we have on
on-prem within a week.
Now, one of the
challenges we have to face
is how scalable this would be
and how fast we could actually
aggregate those data.
So if you look at the
production volume,
we're looking at
around 20 terabytes
of data, which is
250,000 messages
per second translates to 20
terabytes of data every day.
And if you have a
10 minutes window,
you're looking at
150 gigabytes of data
accumulated within that period.
And we are
aggregating those data
so that it doesn't have
a system lag in it.
So the way we did this is--
and it's a very simple process--
by using Java Beam inbuilt
transform called JsonToRow.
So think about, as we are
getting all the JSON rows,
we convert them using inbuilt
function called JsonToRow.
Which is really
good, because now
that we have row object or row
type, what it can do on row
is every row is
associated with a schema.
And it could group by to the
field name or the column name
very easily, and also add a
deaggregated function do it.
So for our use
case, it was more,
so you're going to
group by subscriber ID,
and you're going to group
by the destination subnet.
And then you apply
aggregate function
like min, max, average.
So if you look at the
number of features
that we have, it's pretty
much we're aggregating data
in that window, and
we're trying to find out,
what is the min/max average for
transmission receiving bytes?
What was the duration?
What is probably the
proximate count or number
of IPs within that time frame?
So if you look at on
the screenshot we have,
you're looking at estimated
size of only 11 gigabyte, which
is a very small window.
And after aggregation, you
could see that it comes down
to close to only 1 gigabyte.
So the key thing was that
hey, it was really scalable,
and it was really easy to build
such a pipeline without just
using the inbuilt transform
and let the Dataflow handling
all the scaling issues for us.
So let's go to the next one.
So now that we have data on--
so we are using
a partition table
because it's a 20 terabyte
data combination every day.
And the reason we're
using a data partition,
because when you retrain those,
use those features to retrain,
we don't want to go back
to all the historical data.
We probably only care
about the last few days.
And that's why we're
using the data partition.
And it was super simple
for us to do, just
to use a SQL statement.
You could just create a
k-means clustering now
that you have your data
on a partition table.
And within 15
minutes, we actually
trained close to
terabyte-scale data,
and it's completely segmented
with different clusters.
And it also allows
us to evaluate.
So for example, we
wanted to it try out
with different
numbers of clusters,
what the DB index looks like.
And we found our sweet
spot was number of cluster
when it was used with four.
So now that the
data is segmented,
we're actually not done yet.
We have to do a little
bit of normalization.
Now, the way we did
normalization, so now
think about all the
central cluster we had.
And we went through each cluster
and found all those points.
And using standard
deviation function,
we just created a
normalized distance.
Now, that is the
normalized distance
that we're going to use later
for [? outlier ?] prediction,
online prediction.
Now, another
challenge for this one
was how soon you're
going to retrain, right?
So using a scheduled query,
along with the stored
procedural multi-statement
SQL support,
we just save the query and
re-run when you want it to be.
And we could also do
the version control,
so that if you wanted
to change some schema
or change some of
the features, we
could easily do that as well.
So let's go to the next one.
So now that we have
our normalized data,
what we did is--
so for BigQuery ML, one of the
things that you have to know
is that you could
actually import it
as a TensorFlow model.
And you could import
it on a GCS bucket.
We used a very similar approach.
What we did is we directly
query our normalized table
from Dataflow when it starts
up and use it as a side input.
So now that we have those
normalized information
available, and side input only
operates within the 10 minutes,
the 5 minutes aggregation
window that we have,
so it's going to be
refreshed automatically
as our pipeline process data.
So if you recreated
the model, you
have a new normalized
factors, Dataflow pipeline
should be able to see, is
whether they're actually doing
any downtime or [INAUDIBLE].
Now, how we are actually
doing the outlier detection?
And it's a two-step process.
We used Apache
Commons map functions,
just calculating
distance function
that we could easily leverage.
So the step one was,
we needed to find out,
now that we are getting
all the input vectors
data, so step one
was to find out who
is the closest centroid, right?
Which is the closer centroid
for this input vector?
Once we know that centroid
information, based
on the normalized distance that
we have calculated earlier,
we put it together.
We put them in a
standard scoring system,
and if it's three standard
deviation above mean,
or two standard
we know that that could be a
good candidate for outlier.
So if you look at the diagram
I have on the right-hand side,
so we have three different
clusters showing,
and you could see that
there is one point which
is way farther than
our center point,
or the standard
deviation distance,
but there is also a normal point
which is within the boundary.
So that's how we know if
it's an outlier or not.
Now, finding a single
outlier may not be enough.
We are trying to look
for a pattern of outliers
to be able to see that,
hey, there may be something
going on in terms of security.
Now, another screenshot
that I have right
now, you could see that
for the feature extraction,
it's really great.
So we started the
features, and we're
going through the DLP transform.
And then, we put it back
inside to our partition table,
but with the same feature
extent also branched out
to our anomaly detection
transform, which
is getting all the anomalies
data as a side input.
And then within the
anomaly detection,
we are doing those
two operations
that I just mentioned.
And then we stream
those data it found,
we stream those data
to the outlier table,
hoping that, hey, someone is
going to start looking at them,
and to find hey, if it's
really a risk or not.
OK, so in summary,
you can see we
have built an end-to-end
serverless anomaly detection
solution in less
than a full week
that successfully processed
250,000 events per second using
Dataflow, which comes down to
around 20 terabytes of data
daily accumulation of data.
We have trained and evaluated
a terabyte-scale data
by using BigQuery ML
in less than 15 minutes
and found outliers
in near real-time.
If you're more interested to
learn about this solution,
please check out the
detailed link in here.
Hopefully, you'll
find this talk useful,
and thanks for listening in.